hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to vilasa box game
recommended by you because some people
wanted to see me rage but you don't know
the skill that I have when it comes to
games so you're just gonna hold my god
press up to what huh okay alright this
is totally different than anything I
seriously did not play this game before
this happened oh okay well then oh my
goodness I am NOT okay I'm I'm not gonna
do good at this game I can already tell
oh if I had an oculus rift right now I
would be losing my lunch and it would be
sprayed all over the webcam for you to
see good lordy Lou I am not prepared
okay seriously I didn't even see a video
of it
ah this is level 1 Oh level 1 I don't
blow it's randomized ha ha ha ha got
your number now oh I don't even think
you know what level 1 means I don't even
think you know what beginner means that
was a tutorial that I'm gonna be jacking
10 minutes
oh ha oh oh this to me people ha ha ha
ha oh my god okay brain needs to move
into a different mode right now because
oh my goodness I am sorry if all my
viewers out there gonna fall oh I did it
ok I I screwed it up Oh level 1 what I
think I think the system is basic you
have to AH it is it's not as uh it's not
necessarily about how far you get it's
about how many of these point do dog
I'm trying to explain what's happening
game please do not do Sh with me I do
not appreciate it huh oh goodness
Oh gravy buckets is God this is gonna be
fun oh I'm getting worse I was good I
was so good it's like all my games like
it's so bad and then I huh
cuz I'm talking I need to not talk if I
don't talk my god don't do that to me
cuz I don't know what's happening oh oh
yeah I can jump I can g up with the
flippy I don't even understand oh you
need to let me think for two seconds
because if you don't I'm gonna go oh I
think this someone can cut up the audio
in this game and actually turn it into
some weird oh oh
finish just provide you with all the
grunts you'll need to make that
fanfiction come to life ha oh ho I got
you now
oh you think you're too tough I got a
look ahead that's the thing I got a look
ahead of where I am because this is just
messed up beyond all belief and then
when I flip I got a not get turned
around because I think that's Asia I
gotta think ahead goddamn you got stuck
understand this is friggin impossible ah
ah it's always such an impact to my
chess what they got hot oh the wrong way
why does that scary yeah you want a
battle guy that's crazy notion when I
started rabid off paying Moses we're
flow if someone doesn't remix my all my
moans by the time this is over I will be
ver oh I thought I was dead there oh you
made me think I was dead
Oh turn this is your eyes for a second
there
all I want are we gonna do this again I
send up a bag of [ __ ] you whoa
I know y'all type it away in the
comments we're all your Oh anybody could
be good at this game
no yeah yeah was good [ __ ] it's like
whoa okay that was different you changed
up the rules
I almost appreciate it I'm not gonna be
okay I'm gonna be okay you know what I
didn't use II I thought my rage game
days were over I didn't even think that
this is really gonna be retaken I
thought this was gonna be a fun game
where we have fun times together we'll
hit a pillar
every time I flip upside down it messes
with my head I think I need to go right
when I need to go left there like an
intelligence deficiency that's me
telogen deficient mark okay level two
you think you battle yeah that's a crazy
notion why start flowing on Samos on
first now oh oh I think I'm getting
better at this I think it's gonna be
okay yeah yeah yeah yo yo oh yeah
come on okay hook well I wasn't in the
middle before but I guess I am now as I
said the initial stage of frustration is
over time for me to show off my
incredible skills at gaming
yeah level tool know incredibly skilled
and incredibly handsome market buyers
hexes thieves I take the world or the
world or whatever the hell his name is
[ __ ] man the anus yep
yes oh yes
come on oh you [ __ ] Maya I'm okay
OOP yes come on dawn come on you douche
come on you do sure skwerkel survive on
an Oregon survival pickle I'll kiss him
don't waste over there is moving fast
don't sue in need haha I want to be a
winner in the eyes of my audience
they think I'm a loser hahaha okay
easy peasy lemon squeezy is it easy oh
[ __ ] Piketty figgity [ __ ]
oh no not all boat boat level two in my
book
yeah whoa - boink boink that's how you
do it that's not how you don't rebel -
yup he'll jump don't you come here near
pop never ever ever Bogart you [ __ ] you
you can't do that all right
I was due to the laughing whoa what did
you come B buddy you think you're gonna
Bessel guys like babies you think you'll
battle Italy so what'd you think
how would you Julie wibbly-wobbly oh you
think you're so clever are you in please
look level yep yep yep ah
Austin
huh I better go someday I'll be good at
this you'll release your targeted
Twitter I feel the force within me feel
some within me it is a clown or a pig ah
no bozos bozos oh yeah oh oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah what you
guys oh that's what you're good I don't
even know what I'm babbling about
sure oh yeah no it's all I care about
alright come on bring it on well you got
ha del you got gosh yeah ball true
oh no what are you doing here huh trying
to trick me work usually May gives us to
relieve stress after a long day of
working by playing games I can't look at
the Karma sarcastically until I'm dead
yeah Doubletree you Yehudi how about you
boo boo boo be boo boo boo boo yo daya
boy died a big fat Pam but Dora
put [ __ ] yellow tree the MOA tree
come on you oh no no no no no no oh god
I made it I can't believe it I did it
oh my god oh yes yes yes yeah I did it I
did I beat it
I beat again I'd be a hard game you do
that
thank you all so much for watching thank
you all who believed in me the whole way
and thank you all who doubted me the
entire way thought this day was gonna
end with me range would've did you but I
won I won I won I did mark of r1 thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
I did it i freakin bet it okay